[Music]
hello and welcome to this the very first
episode of night city wire a brand new
series from us at CD Projekt RED where
we'll be talking about all things
cyberpunk 2077 for today's episode we'll
be starting with a brand new trailer one
of our developers will be joining us to
help unpack everything you're going to
see we'll have some news an announcement
about a secret collaboration we'll be
taking a look at some brain dansgame
play and welcoming back our developers
just to have a chat about everything
you're going to see but there is one
more thing media all over the world have
been getting hands-on with cyberpunk
2077 and when this episode finishes
you'll be able to go and check out
exactly what they thought so let's get
started it is time to take a look at our
brand new trailer and after that I'll
lead quest designer papal fasco will be
joining us because I've got a feeling
you're gonna have a few questions after
watching this so let's take a look city
of endless opportunities ready to get
your cherry popped
come on city like any other
it's bigger mine are not just any other
city legends are born here
a chewy brownie your cos Dex is pulling
the strings doubt that putski saying we
do them but we are they just don't know
it yet but if you got the cojones and
you know how you can do damn near
anything unless you catch it for even
then you go out with the bag right you
know you can make heaps more a
motivational speaker yo mr. V a pleasure
so what's the game Dex
you need to come out in one piece how
about we go over the plan there's this
prototype Chet biochip to be precise
jobs to grab esna belongs to a court in
Arisaka niryabi some heavy hitters like
you can blackmail me [ __ ] powers have
a war first rule of the afterlife to cut
teeny baby
it goes without saying and we do this on
the hush I deal e nobody's not a one
sounds simple enough
[Music]
we're gonna be dangerous don't you worry
number one we're bulletproof what the
[ __ ] happened in there
it stopped do goodnight happy now Jackie
[Music]
Thanks what the [ __ ]
game risk Fe and you who are you
[ __ ] so the trailer contains footage
from the games prologue only but there
was an awful lot in it so Pavel why
don't you try and help us unpack
everything that we just saw oh yeah I
mean absolutely I can try so would you
have just seen it's only the prologue of
the game so that awesome stuff is only
happening in the first few quests what
the trailer show you who is really our
stage the night CT you know this
gigantic city build of six completely
unique districts surrounded by the
seventh one that we call the badlands as
a player you are meeting Jackie Jackie's
your friend
now they together are trying to reach
out for something that is very precious
they were trying to reach out for this
chip of immortality this gateway to
eternal life Jackie introduces you to
fix her Dexter DeSean he's a very
important person in a social ladder of
cyberpunk
he is able to provide the player with
various jobs and contracts to be able to
gather money to be able to modify their
bodies push themselves to the limits to
put their hands on a chip but as you can
expect not everything goes as planned
and but to to see it you will have to
play the game there are an awful lot of
really cool things in this trailer and
there's a few that I would just love to
talk about a little bit more for the
people at home so let's start with
talking about a gang called the mocks
now we see a few flashes of them in this
trailer I personally think they're
really cool on one of my favorites but
can you give us a little bit more
information about them oh yes so the box
is one of the gangs that player is going
to interact with throughout the game the
box is the gang that has been formed in
2076 after death of Elizabeth Borden she
was called lazy now she was an owner of
a brothel and former sex worker
she was protecting working guys and
girls from harassment from abuse and the
gang is really continuing her mission
and as a player you are going to
interact with that gang meet multiple
different NPCs and craft your own
relationship with them and understand
what they are all about so earlier on
you did mention a seventh district a
place called the badlands now we saw a
few shots of this in the trailer but I'd
love for you to give us a bit more
detail about the district outside of the
city walls okay so the badlands is this
like dead dried-out space going around
the whole night city and as a player
you'll be able to traverse that space in
your car and motorcycle this is a space
that is inhabited by the nomads nomads
are living in a different families and
they're traveling across that space in
convoys made out of the cars and
motorcycles and as a player you'll be
able to traverse an axis different type
of open-world content that has been
prepared specifically for you to that
get that awesome feel of the badlands as
an area in the trailer we also saw like
a completely metal creature now he
didn't look like he was from the
Maelstrom gang this looked like
something else so this other people at
home who is this giant metal monster
okay so so the big dude that was atom
smasher he has been introduced in a pen
and paper in cyberpunk 2020 by our
senpai Mike one Smith atom smasher is a
fully converted cyborg he is who was
always a loyalist of Arisaka and time
has changed and in 2077 he had to find
his own space in night city but to find
out you have to play the game in this
trailer we do see some flashes of a
ripper doc core Victor vector I think if
people have watched our previous
gameplays they might remember him but
I'd really like for you to give the
people at home some more information
about what Ripper dogs are and how
they'll be interacting with them when
they play cyberpunk so rip or dogs in
our game
they are surgeons they are like a
specific type of a job in the social
ladder of Cybermen
they are accustomed and specialized in
replacing limps to the metal ones they
can basically update your body enhance
your body change you into this
walking war machine and as a player you
are going to move different kind of
Reaper ducks in the game craft your own
relationship with them some of them are
like important characters for a for a
story to that you will invest Eddie's
that you're gathering to turn your body
into this tool that allows you to
survive on the streets of night see
pavel thank you so much for joining us I
know you'll be back later in the episode
because you're gonna be helping us to
analyze the brain dansgame play but
before that we do have some news to
share
earlier in the year we announced that if
you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on Xbox one
you'll be able to play it on xbox a
series X when the console launches and
just in case you missed it it will be
the same for PlayStation players as well
if you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on
PlayStation 4 you'll also be able to
play it on playstation 5 when the
console launches and that's not all
there will be a free upgrade for Xbox
series X and Playstation 5 but we'll
have more details on that soon tonight
city before we reveal our first look at
the brain dansgame play and welcome back
our developers for a chat there is just
one more thing we want to announce
something that we've been working on in
secret for a while we are very excited
to announce our partnership with studio
trigger and netflix to bring you
cyberpunk edge runners a standalone
anime set in the cyberpunk universe
which we've been working on for some
time now edge runners is due to launch
in 2022 but for some more information
let's go to the team in Tokyo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is saya elder I am the Japan
based producer for cyberpunk it runners
what I do basically on this project is
that I am a fixer to put it in the words
of the cyberpunk universe we are a game
company we are a bunch of nerds and
wherever there are nerds there's gonna
be on eBay fans so it's with all we a
dream for us to make on eBay when we
began this project we were certain that
we didn't want to make a recreation of
the game
cyberpunk edge runners is a standalone
story set in the same universe the stage
is still night city but everything else
is totally new new characters new story
I do like to think that it's going to be
a great gateway for newcomers to come
and check cyberpunk game and also the
cyberpunk genre as a bowl
right now we're in Nakano which is one
of the biggest anime of mecca's of the
world I'm gonna take you to studio
trigger right now because we have the
wonderful opportunity to talk to the
dream team that will be bringing you
this anime goo JA Hyuk no Watzke this
can talk no you might see this character
design your turn to through your
snugness give me no no they concur has
you made a good advocate at Yahoo any
Mantzoukas theta decay do any anime
looks good as well
yes your establishment congressman so I
don't Punk to you bucola dude I know you
hungry so you never Coronel America's on
you so you don't wanna know what it is
it's like a ransom state it's good to
you know you in trauma sweetest you to
legal junetta today welcome to any image
collector did I mean personally to
Oregon psycho knowledge in the 20 car to
show Nate Sachi Cikini stick tight to my
mas
Thomas really
[Music]
now it's time to show you some gameplay
of brain dance this is a feature that
you'll experience when you play
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance is
essentially a recording of somebody
else's experience it allows you to
relive their sense of sight smell touch
and even hearing all thanks to a special
device after the gameplay I will be
welcoming back pal Sasuke
I will also be joined by Patrick Mills
our senior quest designer and all-round
law master who will be helping to answer
your questions and give you some
explanation on how you'll be interacting
with brain dance when you play cyberpunk
2077 so let's take a look planned simple
do nothing odd don't get creative you go
in snatch the cash
get out and we sell the Biddy to go
psycho freak snow studio got it got it
and remember everything on full blast
don't spot us extra for a wicked
adrenaline high
okay on you go
now everybody on the graph what I see
you kissing the flooring money now
I will [ __ ] drop you I swear to God
well yeah yeah now slow deep breaths
your cortisol and adrenaline spikes but
the soft activated your hormone blockers
nothing happened
you're alive and well that was too much
felt could feel the guy's pain his dress
his hope hope wrapped up in something
else
mmm-hmm probably took a booster just
before you'll be fine got everything set
up let's switch over to editing mode
I'll sever the link to the BD rollers
sensory array you'll be able to look
around three holes in yours full cam
control and analysis mode so move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up so analysis mode you control playback
can even pause when you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause and try it planned simple do
nothing odd don't get creative you go in
snatch the cash get out and we sell the
BD to those psycho freaks from the
studio got it got it
dream is hell right well that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like give it a try
rewind roll it back to the top now try
that forward
planned simple okay you can also reset
the recording that'll take you right
back to the beginning try it
now for some fun bears here's why you
came in the first place in analysis mode
you get to you and even scan details of
the enviro recorded by the BD roller
focus on the heat the gun that God gets
from his buddy at the beginning now
scanning
plans simple do nothing god don't get
creative you go in snaps for cash okay
right here excellent let's move on now
heads up in analysis mode you can ferret
out background noise and conversations
if the world about personality this tech
record everything every little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of to see the sources of
the recorded sensory signals switch to
the audio layer in the editor go ahead
and try that now okay good now you
should see several sound signatures in
the store choose one and holding on
pack of six case of broseph and a couple
of peppers okay we have a dude today of
two flavors Cody
everybody so any thoughts unbelievable
seriously like what's happening right
next to me yeah it's an LBD recording
implants work they pick up everything
all the elements in the background then
editor tweaks makes them pop keep
playing with the sound explore it a bit
we'll move on when you get bored
what our saviors in the flooring money
yes sometimes you can analyze extra
layers and the raw stuff the roller is
fiber where picked up like what Ed's got
Carosi optics that grab infrared meaning
you should be able to grab heat
signatures from her recording huh hello
nice scanning works on peeps - welcome
to the wounded chicken try scanning her
alright next thing scroll forward to the
part where our artists it's a lead
injection they shot him any never but
you will here it comes
my favorite part of the game see the
blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam must have caught our
shooter you'll see in a second cam feeds
to the screen behind the clerk roll back
to where the screens and the kids field
of vision then scan it
his own June bad shot him probably
planned to all along musta got a nice
LASIK read on the black market for a BD
like this BD freaks are ready to pay a
premium for real flatline anyway if
you've seen enough yeah suppressive
right
too bad most of the beauties we do here
are only good for flog and relock so
brain downs is a pretty big part of the
cyberpunk universe it's not just
something used for adult films there is
an awful lot to it and there's two sides
I'd really like you guys to help me
explore first is the law so how this
actually fits into the universe and then
there's the gameplay side so how players
will be interacting with it so Patrick
could you tell us more about the lore of
brain dance
I would love to so in the world of
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance was invented
way back in the early 2000s at UC Santa
Cruz it was developed as a way of
recording a person's experiences and
then playing them back for someone else
as so that they could relive them as
though it was happening to them it was
originally used for things like therapy
and prisoner rehabilitation but by 2077
it's become this global media industry
including things like movies mass mass
entertainment things like that video
games some interactive things and of
course adult fare as well now in our
game we deal a lot with black brain
dances or X PDS as we call them and
there are different types of those but
the one that you saw in the trailer just
there was a flat liner now that's where
the person recording it actually dies
during the recording and it's popular
with sort of an illicit kind of a thrill
but a mercenary can also use them for
various things and you'll see that in
the game of course and from the gameplay
perspective we have been working a lot
throughout last years trying to figure
out the best way how to use the brain
dance in the game as a mechanics so what
we have settled on is this Brandon's
editor mode as a player you will be able
to run the Brandon's in the editor mode
and see different clues that have been
registered on the peripheral
of given actor now as a player you can
slide on a timeline of the recording
back and forth trying to uncover
different clues and that clues are
actually telling a story in the game so
as a player you will run different
investigations that will lead you to
different mysteries and you will uncover
them actually using the brain dance as a
mechanics in the game
so as Pavel was saying we use brain
dance as a storytelling tool it's not a
collectible it's not something where
you're going to go in and you're gonna
play it and you're gonna be like I've
seen this before what we use brain dance
for is to give you a keyhole into the
life of the residents of night City and
we can explore things like childhood
trauma religion various philosophical
ideas in a way that you might not
otherwise experience in a story about a
mercenary on the tough streets so we've
tried to talk about some of the aspects
that we think the community will find
really exciting but you know while
you're both here I'd love to know what
is it about cyberpunk that you guys are
really excited for Patrick why don't you
start so one of the things that I'm most
excited about in this game is the
characters and the way they interact
with the world we've got this really
interesting world that stretches all the
way back to the cyberpunk 2020 source
material and all of these events and all
those things but those don't mean
anything unless they connect with
characters and so when we come up with a
character we start with their function
what is this person what do they do in
this story but we don't stop there we go
back and we figure out what was their
childhood like what was their upbringing
like what kind of obstacles did they
face in this harsh reality and did they
overcome them and how did they overcome
them or did they not overcome them and
why and you can see all of those things
in their environment in their dialogues
in sort of how they operate in the world
and we come up with for all of our
characters now you look at someone like
Victor vector and you're gonna see
stories about his past in his
environment and in his dialogue you know
we come up with that stuff even if we
don't use it in the game because it
helps inform us as to who these
characters are and for me I would not be
myself if I would not say that I'm the
most excited about our quests like
without which
we teamed with with Patrick and like
everybody that has stayed with us since
The Witcher 3 time we really have grown
so much we have learned so much and we
have used all that experience to put
them into the quests that we have made
and you will not find really a filler in
this game like everything has a meaning
like we put so much effort into making
sure that everything is rewarding he's
interesting is talking about characters
as patrick said it's talking about
worlds it's talking about emotions like
touching the player and they're really
like a real way and I just can't wait to
find out what you think Pavel I know you
mentioned story and quests and writing
quests and when I was last in the studio
I had a look and I saw a notebook on
your desk and I would love for you to
show everybody this notebook you asked
for it so this is a my notebook it's as
a Southwest designer the reason is
because I dance salsa and I'm a quest
designer so I wrote started this
notebook actually when we were really
starting cyberpunk at the very beginning
I wrote it like a first note and it says
pretty much something along the lines of
it that we were starting with a
prototype and then you know I kept on
the basically noting things that we've
been working on for like next years I
remember once when our concept artists
actually approached me and they said
that they want to take a look at my
notebook I was like what for actually
and they they took some pictures and
they told me yeah well you know because
we are looking for a reference material
for a notes of a psychopathic killer so
so yeah well you may find maybe some of
my notes in the game Pavel and Patrick
thank you so much for joining me I'm
pretty lucky because I have read some of
the stories that you and the team have
written for brain dance and I'm pretty
excited for people to discover them but
before we do finish today's episode
there is just one more thing we'd like
to talk about
earlier in this episode I mentioned that
media have been getting hands-on with
opening of cyberpunk 2077 and they
should be posting their impressions
right about now and if you missed
anything from today's episode don't
worry we'll be uploading everything to
our channels very soon and finally on
behalf of everybody at CD Projekt RED we
just want to say thank you so much for
joining us for this the very first
episode of night city wire but don't
worry we'll be back with episode 2 in
just a few weeks so we shall see you
soon
[Music]